chaos has returned to the streets of
cairo
pro-military supporters attacked those
loyal to the ousted president
mohamed morsi bullets fire bombs and
rocks
all fill the air
many have died and hundreds arrested it
was supposed to be a day of celebration
the army marking 40 years since the 1973
war with israel
despite the violence the party went on
egypt's military commanders shown on
state tv
enjoying a laser show and night of
fireworks while the fighting continued
we learnt in the army never to forget
and we will never forget you standing
with us
and before anyone hurts you we would die
first
and ensure that you are never hurt
there were fireworks on the other side
of cairo being thrown in anger
the fighting escalated and with it the
number of dead grief on both sides
adding fuel to the fire
with neither side seemingly prepared to
change course
it's a fight destined to claim more
lives in egypt toby sadler
sky news